[Music]
[Music]
at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
acquitted donald trump found not guilty
of incitement to insurrection
as his second senate impeachment trial
concludes
former president says the make america
great again movement
has only just begun while president
biden says his thoughts are with those
who stood guard at the capitol we're
live in washington dc
also this morning lockdown skeptic
conservatives call on the prime minister
to speed up the relaxation of covet
restrictions
as reports suggest picnics and parts
could be allowed from the 8th of march
it comes as the vaccine rollout prepares
for its next stage with people aged 65
to 69
and the clinically vulnerable invited to
get their jab from tomorrow
fighting for the forgotten sky news
speaks to an asylum seeker on hunger
strike to protest over the quality of
food
being provided as they wait to have
their claims heard
england cricketers are facing an uphill
battle against indians bowlers
at the second test in chennai they've
already lost informed captain
joe root
it's another cold start over eastern
parts of the country but that's not the
news today
it's going to be very windy with gusts
in excess of 60 even 70 miles per hour
but all of that is bringing milder
conditions all the weather details
coming up shortly
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the newspapers with the
anthropologist marianna hotter and ellie
green
from the policy exchange
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
donald trump has been acquitted in his
second senate impeachment trial
in which he stood accused of incitement
to insurrection over last month's
capital riots
seven republicans voted with democrats
with 57 senators in total
voting to impeach and 43 voting to
acquit
meaning the vote fell short of the
two-thirds majority needed for a
conviction
in a statement mr trump said the make
america great again movement
is only just beginning while in the last
few hours president biden has said his
thoughts
with those who stood guard on the 6th of
january our u.s correspondent cordelia
lynch
reports from washington the respondent
donald john
trump former president united states is
not guilty as charged in the article of
impeachment
donald trump impeached for inciting an
insurrection
now acquitted at the site of the siege
the senate the trial revived the human
horror
of a protest that became a riot
you fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
democrats argued mr trump explicitly
directed the mob on january the 6th
he named the date he named the time and
he brought them here
and now he must pay the price they tried
to convey the lasting consequences of
that day
the officers who struggled to recover
from the injuries they sustained
to protect us
they struggle to recover today the
defense team though won out
claiming the trial was all driven by
political vengeance
mr trump's words simply normal political
rhetoric
congress has no authority no right and
no business holding
a trial of citizen trump let alone a
trial to deprive him
of some fundamental civil rights
in a lengthy statement his client
delivered a familiar lament
and hinted at a comeback this has been
yet another phase of the greatest witch
hunt
in the history of our country mr trump
said no president has ever gone through
anything like
it in the months ahead i have much to
share with you and i look forward to
continuing our incredible journey
together
to achieve american greatness for all of
our people
but the former president has exposed a
deep tension in his party
listen to the incredible unease of the
most senior republican
who voted to acquit there's no question
none that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
democrats viewed that excoriating speech
rather dimly what we saw in that senate
today
was a cowardly group of republicans
who apparently have no options because
they were afraid
to defend their job respect the
institution
in which they served what everyone must
now
accept is donald trump has a firm grip
on his party
and however uncomfortable it may make
them feel
they've cleared the path for him to run
in 2024.
cordelia lynch sky news washington
well adam parsons is uh live in
washington for us this morning so adam
uh donald trump lives to fight another
day but
how damaging has the second impeachment
trial been to him
if at all i don't think it's been
particularly damaging
for him uh in any way because the simple
fact is that the people who don't like
donald trump don't like him probably
even
more now and the people who already did
like him think that this
was a great big witch hunt and that he
hadn't done anything wrong so i think
you probably have entrenched positions
clearly if he had been convicted
and then ultimately barred from office
then that would have been an
enormous obstacle in the career of
donald trump but
he hasn't been he's been exonerated for
the second time
and in the minds i think of his
supporters and indeed of
him this is another sign that the
political establishment
is out to get him and that he can use
this for all he's worth as being the
sign that
he is the guy who stands up to uh
to washington what it will have damaged
is the republican
party which now is split clearly into
those
who support donald trump uh and those
who don't he is an incredibly divisive
figure but it is worth noting
in the days before this trial a poll for
the economist carried out by yougov
showed that 87
of republican voters had a positive
opinion of him
among everyone else it is next to zero
so
effectively republican voters still
really like mr trump
everyone else really doesn't like him
that is
no surprise to anyone who's watched
american politics over the past few
years and that is why we got that
statement from him today
he's the favorite to get the republican
nomination
for 2024 and in his mind woe betide
anyone
who stands up to him so he was talking
about his his beautiful make america
great again uh campaign we did get a
statement
from the president from joe biden who
certainly took
a much calmer approach he said much of
his focus was on remembering the people
who had defended the capital on january
the sixth indeed those who had died or
been injured but he did also reflect
on the events on the senate floor he had
this to say
while the final vote did not lead to a
conviction
the substance of the charge is not in
dispute even those opposed to the
conviction like
senate minority leader mcconnell
believed donald trump was guilty of a
disgraceful dereliction of duty
and practically and morally responsible
for provoking the violence
unleashed on the capital interesting uh
that he mentioned mitch mcconnell there
i think
mr mcconnell really does sum up this
dichotomy
a man who voted to acquit but at the
same time launched that enormous attack
on mr trump and i think you are seeing
here almost a reflection
of u.s society 57
of americans said that they thought
donald trump
should be convicted 57 of senators
agreed with him but that wasn't enough
to get the conviction
and donald trump doesn't just live to
fight another day i think he's probably
emboldened
adam thank you a group of
lock down skeptic conservatives have
written to the prime minister calling on
him to commit to a timetable for lifting
covered restrictions
with a complete end to controls by the
end of april it comes as reports in this
morning's papers suggest picnics in
parks with one other person not in your
household
could be allowed from the 8th of march
meanwhile the next stage of the vaccine
rollout begins tomorrow morning more on
that with melena vaselinovich in just a
moment but first let's go to our
political correspondent rob powell in
westminster and rob
uh we seem to be moving closer to
getting to those uh very important
details about what this roadmap out of
lockdown might look like
yeah a week tomorrow jillian is when
we'll get the details uh
from the prime minister plenty of
speculation going on already and
a group of conservative mps some 60 or
so in the covid recovery group
who throughout the pandemic have really
been pressing the case
for easing restrictions today writing to
the prime minister to set out what they
think should happen
essentially agreeing that schools should
be the first thing to go back
on march the 8th but then saying they
want restaurants and pubs open by easter
in a covered secure way
and saying they don't see any reason for
any restrictions to be in place
come may if the government has met its
target of vaccinating
the top nine priority groups all over
50s
by then that timetable i think is
ambitious i think that will be
too fast for um how rapid the prime
minister wants to go
albeit i think there was a different
tone from boris johnson yesterday
usually questions about easing lockdown
is met with a stock reply that it's too
early to talk about that yesterday
boris johnson said that he was
optimistic and laid out
in broad brush strokes anyway how he
would go about lifting the restrictions
no confirmation about when hospitality
will reopen though
no confirmation this morning either
about widespread reports in the papers
that
picnics and outdoor coffees with other
people could be allowed
from early march alongside the return of
schools i think we can be fairly
confident that measures
of those sorts meeting up outside
outdoor socializing
albeit in a limited way will be some of
the first
easement measures that the government
will look to bring forward
i think that's just based on what
happened last time also
what we know about how this virus
spreads
but also the fact that actually allowing
people to meet up and have coffee and
picnics outside with one other person
would only be a very very slight
difference from what we have at the
moment
and melena the vaccine roll out to enter
a new stage this week
right those aged 65 to 69 as well as
people who are clinically vulnerable
are being contacted and invited to book
their covet 19
job nhs england says that 1.2 million
people have
already been contacted in the further
next few days 1.2 million
others will be invited to book their
appointment now this is nhs
england moving down that priority list
onto
the next group this is after ministers
are feeling
rather confident that they will reach
everyone in that top
four groups and vaccinate nearly 15
million people
by monday there is some concern however
that the vaccine uptake has been
lower in some communities and nhs
england medical director stephen powers
has urged everyone who has been offered
a job
to take it because as he says this
disease is not going away
anytime soon coronavirus is certainly
going to be with us for some time to
come
we already have nearly 20 000 people
still in our hospitals
suffering the consequences of this virus
so the key thing is in the months to
come we get
everybody vaccinated who's eligible for
the vaccine
and we start to protect society against
this disease
now some parts of england have already
started vaccinating people over 65
after they've already worked through
their top four priority groups and in
wales the first minister mark drakeford
said that even some people over 50
have been contacted to book that coveted
19 jab
after they reached everyone else in
those top four priority groups julian
malena and rob thank you both let's take
a look now the latest coronavirus
figures for the uk
13 308 new cases of covid19 have been
recorded in the latest 24-hour period
a further 621 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
that brings the total number of covert
deaths in the uk
to 116 908 and
14.56 million first doses of a vaccine
have now been administered
well later this morning foreign
secretary dominic raab will be amongst
sophie ridge's guests
on sophie ridge on sunday as will the
first minister of wales mark drakeford
that's from 8 30 this morning
here on sky news
labour is urging chancellor rishi sunak
to ease the burden of covid related debt
on business
warning hundreds of thousands of firms
could go to the wall without government
support
shadow chancellor annelise dawes says
that from next month
companies are facing the prospect of
having to start paying back
71 billion pounds in government-backed
loans intended to nurse them through the
pandemic
joining me now is martin mctake national
vice chair of the federation of small
businesses first of all what's your
estimation of
government support for business through
the pandemic up until this point has it
been
sufficient yeah i mean the government
support has been very good
as an emergency measure we've seen one
and a half
million businesses supported with bounce
back loans
but we're now entering a crucial period
in the next
three months a lot of government support
will end
certainly at the end of march we'll be
faced with significant corporate
failures our latest estimate
says there could be as many as 250 000
businesses
fail in the next three months yes and
as i said in that that intro uh the
shadow chancellor and lee stoltz saying
that from next month
they're facing the prospect companies
are facing the prospect of having to
start paying back
71 billion pounds i mean
what what are your members saying to you
about that prospect facing that prospect
a very real prospect next month
well many of them are saying it's
completely unsustainable
especially those people in certain high
high pressure sectors like
leisure hospitality and retail
as many as 29 of the people we surveyed
said
that their repayments were more than
their turnover
in the current period so what
what what are they going to do what what
is the advice
what are you saying to them well we're
saying to government that this is
because this is completely unsustainable
we think they have to step in
they have to provide additional support
at the moment what they're saying is
that the debt can be delayed
it could be postponed and some in some
cases up to ten years
but what uh we believe is that all that
will do
is make the businesses balance sheets
completely
uh unsustainable they will not be able
to invest in their businesses they will
only be able to limp on
just about paying the debt that they owe
now that
means that they can't invest in things
like green technology they can't invest
in tech
which everybody has seen over this
pandemic has made a massive difference
the way companies perform so
exactly what are you asking the the
government to do because you're saying
that you don't think delayed
repayment is the way forward
specifically what can they do to help
there are two things we're asking them
to do one is the what we're calling it
contingent tax liability essentially
it's a bit like a student loan for
business
and that will mean that businesses will
only pay back
as their businesses generate profit
and if after a certain period of time
that business can no longer pay it back
that business
that loan is written off the other
option we're
proposing is that the loan can be
converted into employee shares
and we believe that will strengthen the
balance sheet and improve
the productivity and the um the
efficiency of those businesses
and how confident are you that the
government will take these suggestions
on board i mean what's the the dialogue
that you've been
involved in i've got to say it hasn't
been very encouraging so far
uh the government seems to have a view
that maybe the market will take
care of this and we believe that the
signs are so great
that they must step in uh i don't think
there is a market solution to many of
these problems they really do
need to take really important steps now
to correct this
martin mctag national vice chair of the
federation of small business thank you
very much for speaking to us uh
this morning asking for the government
to listen to
their requests thank you
time now for a look at the weather with
joe
hmm it's looking a bit different this
week
a lot different this week warmer
certainly milder yeah we don't use the
word warmer
yes although by next weekend uh we'll be
dragging some air from the far
south and so we could be seeing daytime
temperatures between 14
and 16 contrast that with this weekend
but let's
look at the details for today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well we
are talking about milder conditions this
week but not necessarily
a huge amount of sunshine it is going to
be quite blustery with rain
and also some rather strong winds and
the winds are certainly a feature of
today's forecast gusting at times to 60
miles per hour
and at times this evening for western
parts of scotland up to 70 miles per
hour
so it's still a pretty chilly start
central and eastern parts uh
sub-zero temperatures such a frost risk
of ice as well
a mixture of rain sleet snow freezing
rain over scotland will clear through
the morning
there will be a risk of freezing rain
from the north midlands northwards
throughout the day
but that risk will diminish slowly from
the southwest
so outbreaks of rain across western
parts of the uk may land more persistent
rain over ireland
and the whole lot is moving its way
eastwards through the course of the day
it's going quite slowly
and the mild area is really behind that
second area of rain so as we go through
this evening and overnight
we see those strong winds starting to
ease into monday the rain in the
southeast first thing
a rather grey misty murky start
elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come all the sport with jackie
morning jackie
good morning if you got up early to
watch england's cricketers you're
probably thinking i wish i hadn't
bothered they are really up against it
on day two of the second test against
india we've got all the latest from
chennai for you plenty of wickets have
fallen there
two completely different days for the
top two brazilian goalkeepers in the
premier league
all smiles for man city's edison as
liverpool's allison was left
red-faced and johnny may's spectacular
try gets england back on track
in the six nations and there's a
dramatic game between wales
and scotland we've got all the action
[Music]
it was 10 years ago that i had my
diagnosis and after walking out of the
doctor's office it was a feeling that
mixed up with being
sad feeling so sorry for myself being
angry at the situation
what do we do now and uh and happily
we've been led along the way by well uk
parkinson's uk who
have done a great job not just for me
but for other people who are
always awake on their their lines to
give you any advice
to show you where the best sort of
places to meet people that have this uh
disease
and so they've been pretty good and the
president of the uh charity
is none of the jane asher who has been
talking about us being tantalizingly
close
for some time now and uh this really
does feel like a real thing in this case
this is a bit like going back to the
future
uh going back all those years to
identifying the protein that's so key in
this new research
and then um and then using that
information to bring us up to date and
look beyond
how it can be harnessed the big question
and all the parkinson's people that will
be listening to this right now
we'll want to know when that's the big
thing and i don't think we know that yet
but we're
you know that's what we have had false
stones before but i think this one feels
feels like the real thing as i say we
take you to the heart of stories
that shape our world
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los
[Music]
angeles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back difficult morning for
england's cricketers
in india but a very good one for grigor
dimitrov and serena williams
at the australian open let's have a look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by
[Music]
2025
the world is changing and i'm really
afraid that
being selfish can be our worst mistake
and i cannot allow that
when you think that you are not able to
provide food to your family
i think that's the worst feeling that
someone has
wolves managing nuno espirito santo like
all of us has been profoundly affected
by the pandemic
he wanted to help and approach the
club's foundation with his offer
the result is a 250 000 pounds donation
to feed the pack a project aimed at
reducing food poverty
in a city where 29 percent of children
are living in poverty
it's a common project now it's it's
everybody that wants
to help everybody in wolves
that can give a hand he will do so
it's just a beginning it was great that
he decided that he wanted to support
a project and support the city
ultimately we initially explored a few
ideas about
the type of projects that we could work
together
on and we kept coming back to the need
for supporting people with food at this
most difficult time so
um in the end you know we it was it was
so sort of emotive the whole topic
um that you know it was the one that we
chose out of all the other options
what do you want to achieve from the
project and what do you think it can
achieve
i think it can involve many many people
it can involve everyone
[Music]
companies um
individual and it can bring a spirit
that
we need to to support each other now as
a pack
and when i speak about peck is not only
our friends it's uh it's the city
football has played on through lockdowns
but nuno and his staff have not been
desensitized to society's problems
not having fans here not having that
presence
it's a big blow it's a big blow but it's
not
so big as we are experienced
besides football the society and the
world is on problems you can see
you just turn on the news and you you
get frightened
so and with all these doubts in the
in the future of the people um
it's a moment that showed that that's a
light that's
we're gonna go through this we just need
to stake
to stick together to stay close to each
other
to not being selfish
this is not the right moment to think
about individuals to think about as a
whole is to think about
we which future we want
for the further generations in front of
us this pandemic
will will leave big scars in our lives
and let's try to to make it make it
easier for everybody do you think what
you're doing now and what the
feed the pack project will do is
give people a sense of community that
may not have had it before as well when
people go through
abject poverty they may feel alone
exactly that's
let's not allow them to feel alone let's
give them the sense and the the feeling
that they
have someone and us as a club as a
foundation it's the right moment to do
[Music]
it
it was tough it was brave
it was i didn't quite understand at that
time
what was happening because you know
he was kneeling during the national
anthem
so part of me i thought that was
disrespectful
but then i looked into the the bigger
picture of wiley
he was kneeling you know for police
brutality and inequality
and for someone to put his whole life on
the line
for the better of the people like
he's just inspiration at a time
when doing that was
one of the worst possible times to do it
when there's significant change and i
feel like that flag
represents what's supposed to represent
in this country is representing
people the way that it's supposed to
i'll stand he probably had death threats
probably had you know his life was
probably hell
and for him to do that when it wasn't
fashionable
to do it and just do it for the right
reasons i can't have no more respect for
him
that wouldn't happen in this country not
a chance would i put my whole
career on the line for the greater good
at that time without having to think
about it
probably not so for him to do that it's
just inspirational character
really is everyone's talking about this
black lives matter and this starting
either but
people are talking about now because
it's fashionable like to do that to get
on a knee when
and i know there's a couple other
players at the time but for him to do
that by himself
like he's just i can't put into words
the amount of respect i have for him and
you just said that
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
this is sky news breakfast coming up
samuel speaks to an asylum seeker on
hunger strike
protesting over the quality of food
being provided as they wait to have
their claims heard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to sky news breakfast a
group of asylum seekers
in a hotel in reading are on hunger
strike protesting the quality of the
food they're being given
they say the meals in the temporary
accommodation are leaving many
malnourished
unwell and while charity workers argue
the quality of the food amounts to a
hostile
environment being created for those
seeking refuge in the uk
adele robinson reports we are on day
nine of the hunger strike
was too strong a day feels like a week
here we all think it's going to be a
social person 24 year old
salah is on hunger strike with other
asylum seekers
at his hotel in reading here where i
spent my last three months
for others there it's been over eight
months they're protesting at what they
describe
as lengthy asylum claims and poor food
many people have lost weight some some
of them
had kidney problems we are relating now
uh
so i went more than 10 times to royal
berkshire
hospital with many people
all have very bad conditions
and have a medical problems and because
of the food because because of the food
these photos were taken by asylum
seekers in the south
who say the meals they're given at
hotels is often
an identifiable non-nutritious sludge
lots of vitamins thank you you're very
welcome
in west london a charity says it's
trying to plug the gap
this woman didn't want to be identified
she has a four-year-old daughter
it's been miserable she hasn't eaten
healthy food for over five months
no vegetables no fresh milk no cheese no
egg no fish
imagine a kid who's growing and needs
all this protein and calcium she doesn't
get any of this
for the first time in my whole life i've
had suicidal thoughts
there are so many suicidal people in the
same place
the charity helping her says the home
office is thought to give six pound a
day per person
to some companies providing food but
that is subcontracted sometimes
more than once the accusation is that
corners are being cut
we're talking about the most vulnerable
people in our society they've
escaped all kinds of horrific traumas i
wouldn't even want to tell you about
and then get here and and have some hope
that finally and getting to a safe
country
that the asylum that we're said to be
offering
is um genuine and that we are going to
take care of people but actually what
we've got is a hostile environment
the home office refused to comment but
one of the companies involved did
saying clear springs ensures that where
required three meals a day are provided
the food service provided by our
suppliers
is reviewed on a regular basis to ensure
what is provided meets the required
standards
and that feedback from our asylum
seekers is taken into account as part of
that review
salah however says they're not being
listened to and vows to continue the
hunger strike
fighting he says for the forgotten adele
robinson sky news
let's take a look at the other stories
making the news for you now this morning
a
three-day lockdown has been imposed in
new zealand's biggest city
auckland after three new covet-19 cases
were identified
the level three restrictions mean
everyone must stay at home except for
essential shopping and essential work
the rest of new zealand will also be
placed under heightened restrictions
although will not go into lockdown ms
adern said
the government has announced it will
extend a ban on bailiff enforced
evictions in england until the end of
march
but it's been warned the policy is only
storing up future problems
as homeless charities say hundreds of
thousands have fallen behind on their
rent
or have been served with an eviction
notice in the last month alone
thousands of demonstrators have taken to
the streets once again in myanmar on the
ninth
straight day of protests against the
military coup in the country
protesters walked through parts of
yangon calling on the release of the
country's former leader
aung sang sushi despite laws protecting
freedoms
being rolled back in recent days
now after a year in which independent
venues up and down the country have
struggled
a campaign is being launched to
highlight how music venues
are more than just a place where bands
perform today on valentine's day
the music venue trust which represents
hundreds of grassroots music venues in
the uk
wants to hear your venue love stories
joining me now from glasgow is singer
kerry watt and
tour manager dave rice a couple who fell
in love during a tour in oxford
six years ago welcome to you are
how romantic please before we go
anywhere tell us your
venue love story oh well we met on the
first day of a tour
and the venue was the oxford o2 academy
yeah and i knocked on the door and the
first person to open the door
was dave and we spent the night
on this tour getting to know each other
and then fell in love
here we are six years later planning our
wedding
oh wow congratulations so was it love at
first sight with that that knock on the
door
we are framed like we got to know each
other as friends throughout that whole
tour we were both recently out of
relationships
neither of us were looking for anything
and i think that was what was so great
we got to
know each other through like our love of
music yeah
and um and then within like
yeah a month or two we were that was it
and dave is it is it commonplace for
people to
to find love at music venues
yeah i think it's very like the work is
um
it's very sort of isolated but with a
very like connected group
people that you're with all the time so
it's very easy to form strong bonds
um within the music industry itself and
also going to gigs
yeah and not just uh romantic ones but
friendships and i mean we've met some of
our best friends
enters and at shows people that work
behind the scenes as well as the artists
and the bands
and remind us of your role since carrie
you're a singer
and dave your role your job in the music
industry i am a um
touring merchandise manager so i look
after the t-shirt sales and all that but
i also told manage kerry and look after
her and she's on the road
and so you're now asking for people to
come forward with their
venue love stories because um you've
identified this as a phenomena haven't
you
yeah we've kind of worked on and off
with the music venue trust for the past
year
helping promote the venues that we care
so much about and it gave us
careers um and we feel that support for
these grassroots venues particularly
is so important to you know not
obviously the people that work in them
and
people like us that are passing through
and playing these shows
but but the fans who a music venue for
them is a
safe space to escape it's their social
life it's where they
make friends meet their idols discover
their favorite band
and picturing a world without live music
particularly
in britain where the culture and the
history of live music
is so so important is is some a future
that we can't really imagine so
supporting
the music venues trust and encouraging
people today
to share their venue valentine love
stories is something we're passionate
about
so you've got the hashtag venuevalentine
um and what what exactly
do you want people to to get in touch
with what details should they
they pass on so if you've met a partner
a best friend a group of people and
that you really connected with at a
venue
you've got to share a photo of you with
that person or those people with the
hashtag
venue valentine and that will drive a
lot of kind of support to the music
venue trust
and just make people more aware of how
they can get involved
how they can help and the best thing you
can really do
is um is just kind of check that out and
keep up to date with
all the really smart initiatives that
they've got
coming up over the over the next few
months they're always collaborating with
artists and putting on
live stream shows and there's loads to
get involved with
dave uh what what did you do for
valentine's day today may i ask
well it is it is 7 30 in the morning
that's no excuse you're up
making excuses for him kerry
ready for her yeah she's ready for it
yeah thank you both enjoy the rest of
valentine's day enjoy good to speak to
you this morning
it is the time for the weather now joe
i just slipped in i was riveted by that
you were reading your valentine's
cards i was the man took me
anyway the weather let's get to the
scientific bit it's changing much milder
conditions for the coming week
and by next weekend we could well be
seeing temperatures up to around 14 or
16 degrees celsius
not quite the situation this morning but
let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you yes much
milder conditions coming in from the
west
we're going to have a bit of a bumpy
ride as this milder air does
arrive it's going to be wet and it's
going to be windy and right at the
moment because we still do have some
cold air around
we'll see some sleet bit of snow also
freezing rain and that freezing rain
could be anywhere from north midlands
northwards
although the risk will reduce from the
southwest during the course of the day
but yes it's cold for central and
eastern areas temperatures sub-zero once
again
risk of ice and bitterly cold because
we've still got these
strong blustery winds and the wind's
going to be strongest through the
average sea gusting up to around 60
miles per hour
and for a time this evening up to around
70 miles per hour for western parts of
scotland
so we've got rain making its way
eastwards outbreaks of showery rain
through western parts of the uk mainland
all of that moving through the course of
the day the milder conditions come in
behind
temperatures this morning already 11
lightest to rise to 12 or 13 degrees
celsius that's 55 degrees fahrenheit and
we keep those temperatures through the
week
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on sky news breakfast
after the break a look at today's
newspapers with anthropologists marianna
hotter and
ellie green from the policy exchange do
you stay with us
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to
safety rage once for the ones who want
to know more welcome to the all-out
politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
i'm a little bit chaotic sometimes and
things can go flying and i mess up and i
saw tick tock as a whole new platform
where i don't know any of these people
and i thought it was a really nice way
to get a message across to educate
people
and just to show that um you know i want
to teach people in a time that i can't
do anything
at this point i you know the only thing
that i can do is cook and hopefully show
people
how to cook better at home as well and
that's something that i think i've
managed to
achieve i definitely want to break break
down those kind of barriers of
fine dining being a little bit scary and
some of the techniques that i've learned
and some of the things that i've trained
for over my time in kitchens
um it's been great to translate that
into videos where people can be like oh
i didn't know you could use that
um to make these incredible meals that
people are making at home and it's
really great to see other people and my
followers actually making the stuff that
i'm doing when we went into lockdown in
november
i did a series of 25 days of potatoes
and that is kind of what
caught people's eye because i could see
the audience wanted potatoes because i
did one video so
one of my favorite ones is the pom anna
which is
i think just came up on the screen
actually before um where you kind of
layer these gorgeous slices of potatoes
and loads of butter
um so that's one of my favorite recipes
and again people
get to do it at home and then show me as
well which is incredible
for this book i've really reflected what
i've already done on tik tok
and i'm showing people the food that
they need and that's the title of the
book so it's just
helping people um learn
better skills in the kitchen whether or
not i go back into a kitchen
i'm not sure i am really enjoying what
i'm doing and being able to teach people
on a massive scale
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back with us again to take us
through the newspapers this morning
anthropologists marianna hotter and
ellie green from the policy exchange
that they both
are welcome back uh starting with you
first of all ellie in the times
and this story about vaccine trials this
time for children
yes this is quite exciting so children
as young as young as
five are set um to enter this trial
which could begin in a matter of days
and hopefully um this could pave the way
for childhood
immunization a childhood immunization
program that would i guess be in line
with similar programs that we have
for measles and for polio um i mean this
piece is also noting that today will
likely be the day
that the government reaches its target
of 15 million
vaccinated that's the over 70s and
healthcare workers
and they'll now be able to move on to
those who are over 65.
um so obviously the vaccine rollout
being very important
but yeah this new trial looks to be very
promising
and it's exciting news to see that if
children can be vaccinated early on
and that they will then hopefully have
uh immunity and they'll
not have covert as severely there's talk
that they may have to have a booster
later on at some point but this is
definitely exciting news and obviously
would then importantly mean
the children could get back to school if
this vaccine was to prove successful
and the schools would no longer be these
hot spots for um outbreaks
any mention of vaccinating teachers
um not in this piece but i think
obviously that is critical of is of
critical importance and i know the
government have you know spoken about
that
um and hopefully we'll see that that
starts to become a priority
as we as we move over the next couple of
months and we start to
you know to try and get children back
into school because obviously this is
going to be very important yeah mary i'm
moving away from the pandemic for a
moment the observer
uh their article looking at trump's
supporters
and the fact that they're still
supporting him
yeah that's right so uh trump was
acquitted
in his impeachment trial um uh yesterday
uh these um senators voted 57
to 43 so there was an overall majority
but in order for the ex-president to
have been impeached they needed to reach
a two-thirds majority which obviously
they didn't
so seven um republican senators did vote
with the democrats to impeach
trump but obviously that isn't that many
and this article is exploring the kind
of wider landscape
of republican support and particularly
trump support in the us
basically saying that your grassroots
um supporters of trump are still
absolutely committed
to trump and what he represents and his
kind of
agenda and when um pro-trump or
traditionally pro-trump
uh news channels in the us were showing
the details of the impeachment trial
no one watched because basically human
psychology is that if you hold on to a
belief like a
almost like a kind of semi-religious
belief you just
deny the the evidence that that kind of
suggests anything otherwise
some of the republican senators who
voted um uh
to equip trump didn't didn't do that on
the basis that they said that trump
didn't incite the rioters
uh to to march on the capitol building
they just said that there's no
jurisdiction for this court because he's
not the president anymore
so you can't impeach him so this is a
kind of a fake
a phony trial or a false trial at least
um but i think basically that the kind
of question is now
what happened what does trump do if he
had been impeached then he wouldn't have
been able to run for election again
because he's been acquitted he in
principle could stand as the next
republican candidate
and stand as the next american president
but i wonder whether it will be more
likely that he will uh
see his role as king maker he's got
money he's got grassroots support he
tears up a rule book and doesn't really
care what kind of
dirty or otherwise treats well he
basically said watch this space and make
america great again hasn't gone anywhere
and there's more to come
ellie take us to the the mail and some
worrying
claims by um airport chiefs about the
future quarantine
hotel process there there seem to be
issues
yeah i mean so from tomorrow uh
travelers will be forced to quarantine
in these hotel
quarantine um and in hotel quarantines
and
heathrow where vast numbers of travelers
are expected to arrive
has said that there are significant gaps
um when it comes to how they're going to
be able to roll out this program
there's issues around obviously people
queueing and whether or not there'll be
transmission of covered in that capacity
there's also been questions around
whether or not you know if people refuse
to fill out the passenger locator form
or if they refuse to go into quarantine
what the steps will be um and apparently
you know they need more advice on that
from the government the government have
said
that they're in you know continued talks
uh with airports about how
to roll out this hotel quarantine
effectively i mean i think
obviously there'll be a series of issues
that will probably develop over the next
couple of days and weeks
as this program has rolled out um and
there'll be a lot of unforeseen issues
uh that come from obviously quarantining
such vast numbers of people and
travelers that are coming into this
country
yeah very very worrying though very
close to it to be rolled out with such
uh
great issues uh marianne why should
swimming pools open before
pubs this is in the times who's saying
they should
uh so uh perhaps unsurprisingly the
chief executive of swim england
is saying that they should but um jane
nicholson possibly has a point
uh a lot on the front pages you know
we're all getting excited about possibly
non-essential shops opening
maybe being able to go and sit in a pub
garden on the easter weekend
but she's saying hang on a minute
swimming is something that four million
people do at least or used to adults she
um did
at least twice a month and the challenge
is that you can't translate swimming
into
a non swimming pool or or pool based
activity you kind of need the water
unless you want to go swimming in your
local river in february
um and so she's saying you know this is
actually something that if it's a
well-maintained pool if it's properly
chlorinated even the world health
organization say it's safe
so we need to prioritize other sports
other than the ones where you go for a
walk around your local park even though
that is healthy and good but not
everybody can walk not everybody can
use a bicycle and so swimming does need
to be
up there on the priority list because
it's a matter of physical and mental
health
and the healthier the nation um the
better able we are to cope with
i suppose people will be calling for for
gyms to to open as well um because
health is such an important
feature ellie um just quickly time tell
us about this a story on universities
facing fines
for what yeah so in the telegraph
universities will be facing fines
if they've been found to stifle free
speech i mean i think this is very
welcome news
this is something that policy exchange
has worked on extensively both with our
history matters project and also in our
previous reports
looking at academic freedom in the uk
ultimately i think for most people
they see universities as bastions of
free speech
and places which actively encourage
intellectual debate
and so i think that you know the news
that the government is going to really
be proactive
in trying to ensure that uh free speech
is able to thrive on campus
and also that academic freedom is not
threatened um
i think will be really really good news
uh we've just got time for this well
it's more or less a picture story i
i find it just incredible um a woman
pushing a milk lorry
uphill marianne you picked this out
did she really do this this is insane
so we're not talking you know like a
milk floats we're talking about an
articulated lorry
up a hill in fife um it's a lady called
charlene leslie
uh she saw this um truck getting stuck
uh
in the snowy conditions last week and
basically said to a neighbor
oh watch the kids and the dog they're in
the car i'm gonna push this truck up a
hill
obviously totally dangerous absolutely
bonkers please no one ever do that again
uh but it does mean that um the company
said thanks charlene please don't do
that again but um
we'll reward you with a free supply of
milk for the year yeah
is it worth it free milk for a year i
don't know thank you both for taking us
through the papers good to see you
much more at the top of the house
you